more insight into the republican races
for governor and senate here in the
state of nevada our new eight news now
the hill emerson college poll looked at
candidates leading the pack and today
politics now host john langler looks at
issues that matter most to republican
voters the primary is june 14.
struggling candidates need to make their
move now before it's too late with two
front-runners in these two high-profile
races we wanted to see what issues could
sway republicans before they vote we
have a governor more interested in
locking us out of work pointing out
what's wrong is usually how politicians
out of office try to get into office
right now it's hard to miss gop
candidates using that tactic before the
primary the question is what do voters
think is wrong what matters to them now
remember these are republican primary
voters spencer kimball is with emerson
college it conducted a poll of a
thousand likely republican voters across
nevada in the governor's race we asked
which candidate is most trustworthy on
crime
no surprise gop frontrunner and sheriff
joe lombardo leads by a wide margin in
the senate race republican voters say
former state attorney general adam
laxalt is most trusted to handle
immigration polls show he and lombardo
are leading their races turns out
republican voters don't think much of
the work we do 86 percent don't trust
the national media to accurately cover
elections 69 percent distrust local
media in their political coverage still
the election comes as the nation battles
record inflation everything is costing
more our poll shows that is what weighs
on voters more than anything else
44 percent of republicans say the
economy is the most important issue
right now immigration is a distance
second at twenty percent followed by
education and just something else
amongst republicans the economy usually
ranks a little bit higher than let's say
health care and so these numbers are
generally in the trends of what we're
seeing one lingering trend in the gop is
the 2020 election it's still a topic of
frustration even with a new election on
the horizon 56 percent of republicans
that we polled say former president
trump spends the right amount of time
talking about that and unfounded claims
of voter fraud he's already endorsed
lombardo and laxalt in their races going
against the nevada gop they're going to
have to make the case that they're
stronger than either lombardo or laxalt
john langler live local now